Com vocês, o fenômeno da internet.
Whindersson Nunes!
Obrigado, Salvador!
Que coisa linda,
que coisa maravilhosa!
Obrigado!
Uma salva de palmas para vocês!
É.
Muito obrigado,
estou muito feliz de estar aqui hoje.
Eu vim fazer essa apresentação
para vocês
A minha primeira viagem
foi para São Paulo,
aí comecei a viajar mais.
Fora do nordeste, sabe?
Com os shows.
Uma coisa que eu notei,
quem não é do nordeste
tende a nos julgar.
E isso é uma droga, por quê?
Eles acham que aqui
está sempre sol e calor.
Está sempre sol e calor.
"De onde você é?"
"Sou do Piauí."
E a pessoa diz,
"Nossa Senhora, meu Deus do céu!"
É como se eu tivesse o sol no bolso,
e jogasse nelas.
Eu não entendo.
Não posso sentir calor em São Paulo.
Não posso. Se sentir,
tem sempre um que diz, "O que foi?"
"Estou com calor."
"Como assim tá com calor?
Você não é do nordeste?"
E eu digo, "Sou do Nordeste,
mas não sou filho do capeta."
As pessoas... O quê?
É sério, cara.
Tem que ser sofrido.
Eles não acreditam
que sou do Piauí, cara.
Precisa ser queimado do sol.
Sofrido.
De ir buscar água ao meio dia,
com um balde na cabeça.
Meus oito irmãos desnutridos.
Janderson, Wilson,
Wanderson, todos eles.
Todos com "son" no final,
pra parecer mais pobre.
Ninguém acredita.
"De onde você é?" "Do Piauí."
"Nossa, não parece."
E eu falo "Por quê?"
"Porque você é branco demais."
"Na minha casa tem telhado, tá?
Eu tenho telhado."
E é isso. As pessoas me perguntam
se eu tenho uma onça.
"De onde você é?", "Do Piauí."
"Você já vu uma onça?"
Tipo, se eu for pro Japão,
eu vou ver o Goku
no meio da rua?
Pelo amor de Deus!
Não.
É foda.
E a gente é diferente.
Somos diferentes do resto.
Muito diferentes.
As pessoas zoam da gente,
dizendo que temos a cabeça grande.
Não acho que seja um defeito,
é uma qualidade.
A gente é fofo.
Igual aqueles cachorrinhos
que você bate
e eles fazem assim.
Não é bonitinho?
É bonitinho.
Acho bonito.
E eu gosto de ser diferente
das outras pessoas.
Não somos como o pessoal de fora.
O pessoal de fora é muito diferente.
A gente é outra coisa.
A gente é foda. A gente é outra coisa.
Presta atenção.
Não grita agora, só depois.
É sério, a gente é.
Pra tudo a gente tem uma festa.
Pra qualquer situação
fazemos um carnaval.
Imagina que o Harry Potter
foi para São Paulo,
Harry Potter, o menino da magia, do
outro lado da rua, e o pessoal falou:
"Nossa, meu irmão! O Harry Potter!
Nossa, véio. Nossa."
Harry Potter!
Wingardium Leviosa!"
Foi embora o Harry Potter. "Nossa,
meu irmão! Nossa, véi, pode crê!"
Imagine que ele passou
no Piauí minha Nossa Senhora!
Ele passou do outro lado da rua
e o cabra:
"Harry Potter!
Eu te assisto desde pequenininho!
Tu sabe fazer mágica?
Transforma essa pera num pão
se tu for bão!"
Aí pegam ele pelo braço e levam
pra mãe, pai, irmão, todo mundo ver.
A gente gosta disso.
Peido? Ave Maria
O peido é um carnaval!
Não é igual em São Paulo.
Em Belo Horizonte, é assim,
tem seis pessoas, uma peidou,
e a primeira a notar fala:
"Vou pegar uma água pra gente."
E sai,
aí um por um eles vão saindo,
até só sobrar o que peidou.
Porque quem peidou
não abandona o peido.
Ele fica e aproveita a brisa.
"Deu trabalho pra fazer,
vamos cheirar essa porra."
Agora um peido no Piauí,
o primeiro que percebe
faz um escândalo!
Vai ver que nem fedeu,
só fez barulho.
Ave Maria!
"Cagaram!"
Cagaram.
Se vier passando alguém, a gente fala,
"Minha senhora não passa por ali.
Passa aqui.
Tão cagando aqui minha senhora."
A gente faz o CSI peido
para descobrir quem peidou.
Pra quê? Pra humilhar.
E vai ser peidão pro resto da vida.
Tá comendo urubu, seboso?
Vá jogar esse cu fora, nojento.
E gente é criativo.
A gente passa 15 minutos
olhando pro chão,
esperando o cara perguntar o que é.
"O que você está procurando?"
"As pregas do seu cu
que tão por aqui!"
A gente tem disso.
A gente é diferente.
Peido é engraçado.
É um vento que sai do cu, do nada.
É muito massa, não é?
Vou falar uma coisa para vocês agora,
não é piada, é sério.
Eu estava em casa,
assistindo a Sessão da Tarde, sentado.
Eu peidei, e eu juro pra vocês
que falou "Michael".
Juro, eu tava sentado,
de boa, sozinho.
Eu senti, porque a gente sabe
quando o peido é bom.
Começou... e eu disse
esse é dos meus.
Esse é bom.
Aí eu levante a perna,
pra não agredir muito o sofá.
No que eu levantei a perna,
eu ouvi "Michael".
Eu disse, esse peido errou de cu,
eu não sou Michael.
Peido fala.
Tem um tipo de peido que fala
marca de carros.
Sabe aqueles fininhos que
falam "Fiat".
Esse é podre.
Esse é o pior.
Ave Maria!
Já notou que quando alguém peida,
a gente fica com ódio?
A pessoa peida e a gente começa
a falar: "Nojento. Seboso."
"Você é podre, imundo,
ai que raiva de você!"
Sobe um ódio, um rancor na gente.
Mas quando a gente peida, é engraçado.
A pessoa começa
"Seboso, imundo."
"Sim, é verdade.
Sai de perto porque eu sou é podre."
Mas você fica com ódio
quando alguém peida.
Só tem uma pessoa que pode peidar
que você não fica com ódio.
Sua mãe.
A mãe peida e a gente cheira calado.
A mãe tem aquela coisa
chamada "superioridade".
Que é o seguinte:
"Eu sou sua mãe e você cala a boca."
Então quando a mãe peida...
E é podre.
De uma mãe, é a coisa mais podre
que eu já vi na vida.
Nossos peido é peido novo.
Um peidinho de 15 anos vem coxinha,
Coca-Cola.
Um peido de uma senhora
de 45 anos
são 45 anos de ódio.
Chega a arder o olho. O cara fala
"Mamãe, pelo amor de Deus!"
Foi assim que nasceu a conjuntivite.
O peido de uma mãe.
E você não pode dizer nada.
Só que a gente não é burro, não.
A gente dá um indício que sentiu.
Presta atenção, não tem ninguém
em casa, só vocês dois.
Você aqui, sua mãe ali...
Você sente o cheiro.
"Mamãe!"
Só que ela é mais esperta que a gente.
Sabe o que ela faz?
Finge que não aconteceu nada.
Ela sabe por que você está
chamando ela.
Porque o ambiente está inabitável.
Não passa um gato
perto das pernas dessa mulher.
De tão podre que tá.
O cara fala "Mamãe!" e
ela faz só isso aqui:
"O que foi, bebê?"
Quer ver essa mulher virar o cão?
Eu digo: "Você peidou!" e ela "Rapaz!"
Mãe, só tem eu e a senhora aqui."
"Me respeita, filho da puta!"
Ela fala com tanta verdade que eu até
acredito que fui eu.
Chega gente em casa "Que caatinga
é essa?" - "Eu que peidei."
Eu assumo. A gente assume pela mãe.
A gente perdoa a mãe.
Agora, o amigo, a gente
não perdoa, não.
Só está você e seu amigo em casa
e você sente o cheiro.
"Você peidou, né,
filho de rapariga?"
Só tem vocês dois,
o cara faz isso aqui...
"Eu?"
"Só tem nos dois aqui.
Ou você peidou, ou meu cu está
dormente que eu não estou sentindo.
Mas um amigo não consegue esconder.
Não consegue esconder o peido,
sabe por quê?
O sorriso.
O cu tem uma conexão Bluetooth
com a boca.
A pessoa peida, a vontade
de sorrir vem na hora.
E se você pressionar,
você vai descobrir quem peidou.
"Foi você que peidou?"
"Não foi eu, cara, é sério."
Fede pelo olho.
Eu tenho raiva de peido.
Eu tenho ódio de peido.
Peido e espirro.
Espirro, eu tenho raiva.
Você não pode falar com quem
vai espirrar
porque corta o espirro dela.
A pessoa fica com raiva.
Você precisa esperar ela espirrar.
A coisa mais ridícula do mundo
é esperar alguém espirrar
para você poder falar.
Pode prestar atenção, a pessoa
faz assim:
Pare que está pegando energia
do universo.
E você diz, "Vamos ali?"
E você fica assim.
Passou.
Não dá um ódio?
Eu tenho raiva, cara.
Eu tenho raiva disso.
Tenho raiva de catarro.
Tenho muito mais raiva.
Porque meu nariz é grande.
Acho que meu nariz está sempre sujo.
Então o que eu faço?
Eu estou toda hora limpando
o nariz.
E quando vem alguma coisa...
O catarro tem que ser mais estudado
pela ciência,
porque ele tem uma cola
que não é de Deus, não.
Você tira e ele vem pra cá, né?
Aí você faz assim, ele prega
nesse aqui.
O cara passa 15 minutos
driblando catarro.
E ele não sai.
O cara passa no pé e fala "Desgraça!"
E quando olha para a mão...
Ele volta pro dedo.
Dá pra fazer um filme:
O Retorno do Catarro.
Então eu criei uma técnica.
Eu criei uma técnica muito boa,
para não acontecer de novo.
Eu faço o seguinte...
Eu não enfio mais o dedo no nariz
quando eu vou limpar.
Eu vou espremendo do crânio, aqui.
Espremendo, espremendo...
e quando chega na beirada,
o que estiver na beirada,
eu jogo fora.
Meus amigos reclamam,
"Você não coloca o dedo no nariz
pra limpar?"
"Quando você limpa o cu,
você enfia o dedo?"
Não é da beirada?
Então pronto.
Nunca vi ninguém falar,
"Você está limpando o cu?"
Aí você escuta assim...
Não tem.
Nunca vi alguém fazer isso.
Não dá, né, meu?
Eu tenho raiva disso aí.
Eu tenho raiva de cagar
na casa dos outros.
Fiquei nervoso antes de entrar aqui
porque eu queria cagar, mas não aqui.
Porque aqui não é minha casa,
eu fico naquela.
Já notou que
quando você caga na casa dos outros
parece que a bosta é sua amiga?
Ela não quer ir embora.
Ela fica ali com você.
Você dá descarga oito vezes.
Oito descargas.
Nada. Você dá uma descarga, nada.
Duas, nada. Três nada.
Quatro descargas,
ela está na mesma posição.
A posição de quem está descansando.
Quando ela não desce e é assim.
Tá descansando, tá na dela.
Não desce.
E na nona descarga ela vai.
Aí o cara...
Mas depois de três segundos,
ela volta.
Eu estou comendo isopor ou o que
pra ela não descer.
Não quer ir embora, não,
pois volta.
Dá raiva.
Eu tenho ódio.
Coisa ruim.
Eu sei lá...
Tem muitos casais aqui na plateia?
Tem?
Aumenta a luz da plateia.
Ali, ali também.
Como é teu nome, de preto?
Como? Vanderson, né?
É daqui mesmo, viu?
Vanderson!
E o nome da sua esposa?
Como?
Fala com a boca.
Repete por favor.
Fernanda? Fernanda e Vanderson.
Vanderson é nome
de tecladista, né?
Vanderson!
A foto da capa é o Vanderson,
debruçado no teclado.
A paisagem nada a ver
com nada.
A contracapa é a Fernanda, assim.
Quanto tempo estão juntos?
Um ano?
Um ano de sofrência, não é?
Um ano, coisa boa, viu?
Um ano.
Você já trocou de absorvente
na casa dele?
Pode falar, estão só os amigos aqui.
Não tem quase ninguém mesmo.
Nunca?
Quando você troca de absorvente,
você deixa aberto ou fechado?
Pode falar a verdade. Fechado, né? Com
papel higiênico para camuflar.
Isso é muito bom.
Isso aí é um ano, Vanderson.
Passar muito tempo,
ela não vai mais ser tão cuidadosa.
Um dia ela vai deixar aberto,
e você vai ver.
E você vai ter
que estar preparado, Vanderson.
Um dia eu cheguei em cada.
E não estava preparado, Vanderson.
Quando olhei na lixeira
e vi aquela chacina...
Que eu vi aquele tanto de sangue,
"Meu Deus do Céu, minha namorada
fraturou o priqueto.
Fraturou ou quebrou.
Eu não sei se ela foi
dar um pulo e rasgou...
Porque às vezes não está alongado,
né, Vanderson?
Eu digo, aqui morreu.
Morreu.
Recebe, Jesus, essa alma.
Depois de dois minutos ela passou
caminhando. Deus é fiel, Jesus.
Soltou um tanto de sangue desse
e não morreu, deve ser um X-Men.
Eu perguntei,
"O que é isso?"
"Sangue! Não tá vendo não?"
"Vamos fazer uma campanha
de doação de sangue."
Ela disse "Pra quem?" Eu disse
"Pra tu, tu deixou o teu todo aqui."
Amor, isso é porque o absorvente
é diferente.
Eu fui perguntar porque eu não sabia
que tinha diferença de absorvente.
E a mulher, Vanderson,
quando ela sabe que você
não entende do assunto,
ela vai te dar uma lição.
Ela gosta de chamar a gente de burro.
Eu perguntei
"Amor, e tem diferença?"
"Whindersson, você é tão burro.
Existe absorvente com abas.
Sem abas.
Tem até absorvente com cheiro
de rosas do campo."
Eu disse, "Pra que, meu Deus?
Quando bota não fica com cheiro
de rosas do campo."
A rosa do campo morre.
Não nasce mais uma rosa nesse campo.
"Tá bom.
Pois hoje eu vou botar um O.B."
E eu sem saber o que era um O.B.
"Mas o que é um O.B.?"
E ela foi me explicar.
"Um O.B. também é absorvente.
Só que ele é um pouco diferente.
Como eu posso explicar?
Vou dar um exemplo."
"Sabe uma pia?"
"Uma pia?" "É, uma pia.
Quando você não quer que a água
da pia passe pelo buraquinho da pia,
o que você faz?"
"Eu tampo lá no buraco da pia."
Ela disse, "Exatamente".
"A gente tampa lá no buraquinho!"
Aí eu, porra, legal, né?
Vai ajudá-la,
né, Vanderson?
Ela foi lá botar o O.B. porque
a gente ia sair.
E ela colocou.
E a gente foi a um jantar, romântico.
Excelente.
Muito bom.
Um jantarzinho massa, e aí
eu peguei o macarrão,
botei na boca...
Comecei a mastigar. Acho que ela
foi colocar o garfo rápido demais
que uma pontinha do garfo
pegou no céu da boca, fez assim...
Saiu sangue,
e ela não me disse, Vanderson.
E eu aqui comendo,
tranquilo...
romântico...
Top... Proparoxítona...
Falei: "Porra, vou dar um beijo."
Quando eu levantei a vista,
olha o sangue escorrendo,
e eu disse: "Meu Deus do céu,
a pia encheu!
Vai derramar!
Tira!"
Eu sei lá.
Que mulher perturbada!
Só as mulheres vão responder:
sim ou não?
Você namoraria um cara que tem barba
só até aqui na metade da cara?
Então porque as mulheres tiram
o cabelo da perna só daqui até aqui?
No joelho?
E não pode pegar na canela, não.
Ela zanga.
"Tá crescendo os cotoquinhos."
Não gosta, mano!
"Por que que corta só a metade?"
"Porque eu gosto de passar um Loreal."
Aí vai pra praia de biquíni...
Fica daqui pra cá pelado, e daqui pra
cá o Goku. Saia jeans, cabelo.
Vovó era louca.
Minha avó era muio doida.
Vovó com 95 anos
queria andar de bicicleta.
"A senhora é doida?"
"Vou andar!"
Se você prestar atenção,
o velho, quanto mais velho,
a velha, quanto mais velha,
mais grosso ela fala.
E o velho, quanto mais velho fica,
mais fino ele fala.
"Vó, tá fazendo o quê?"
"Tô cuidando dos meninos, aqui."
Pergunta pro seu avô,
"Onde é a concha acústica?"
"Rapaz, você pega por aqui,
vira ali..."
O velho é desse jeito,
ele é totalmente diferente.
Vovó queria andar de bicicleta.
"Vó, não anda de bicicleta." "Eu vou."
Saiu empurrando, deu dois minutos
ela voltou,
o pneu vinha torto,
um olho roxo,
faltando três dentes na ponte,
e eu disse, "Vó, a senhora caiu?"
"Meu filho, meu peito
enrolou no pedal.
Eu pedalei pra desenrolar,
o outro peito enrolou."
Eu disse "Bota no bolso, vó,
pelo amor de Deus."
Vovó é surda.
Vovó era muito surda, cara.
Muito surda.
Vovó era muito surda e vovô,
duas vezes mais surdo.
E eles moravam sozinhos.
No interior, cada casa era
dois quilômetros uma da outra.
Eles só conversavam entre eles.
Uma vez eu cheguei lá
fui na casa da minha avó,
meu avô estava em cima da casa
tirando uma goteira,
mexendo nas telhas, e eu fiquei
embaixo, pose de menino.
E minha avó chamou o meu avô.
"Antônio!
Você tá tirando goteira?"
E ele disse, "Não,
estou tirando goteira!"
E ela disse, "Ah, bom,
achei que estava tirando goteira."
E foi-se embora.
Eu queria saber o que eles escutaram
um do outro.
A resposta foi uma certeza...
É todo mundo louco lá em casa,
meu pai é louco.
Tem algum pai aqui na frente?
Você é pai? Qual é o seu nome?
Seu nome? Márcio?
Meu pai acorda muito cedo.
E pai tem um problema.
Quando ele acorda,
ele quer que a casa acorde com ele.
E você pergunta, "Pra quê?"
"Pra levantar, rapaz."
Ele não quer fazer nada.
Que horas você acorda, Márcio?
Que horas você acorda?
Seis horas.
Meu Deus do céu!
Quando meu pai acorda,
o homem que apresenta o
Globo Rural está escovando os dentes.
Não tem quem aguente.
Minha mãe é louca.
Minha mãe odeia quem tem tatuagem.
Eu sou pintado de tatuagem.
Igual a uma cadeira de escola pública.
Com uns piriguetos, as rolas...
Todo riscado, eu sou. E eu fui fazer
minha primeira tatuagem.
Mamãe odeia tatuagem.
Eu falei...
Tem um momento na vida
do adolescente que ele acha
que manda em casa.
Eu cheguei em casa e disse "Mãe!
Eu vou fazer uma tatuagem."
Ela disse "Você não é mais meu filho!"
"É só uma tatuagenzinha."
E olha a desculpa que ela deu:
"Filho, quem tem tatuagem
bate na mãe."
Meu Deus do céu,
como é que está a mãe do MC Guimé.
Todo dia é oito cacetada.
Mamãe é louca.
"Eu vou fazer tatuagem."
Mãe, é só uma tatuagenzinha.
"Não!"
"Bem pequenininha."
"Mãe, Jesus."
"Não!
Enquanto você morar
embaixo do meu teto..."
Ela fala isso porque a gente
não tem pra onde ir.
"Enquanto você morar embaixo
do meu teto, não faz tatuagem!"
Só que eu saí de casa
com 16 anos.
Eu não moro mais embaixo do teto dela.
Eu vou fazer.
Só que um dia eu ia voltar em casa.
Um dia eu ia voltar
e ela ia ver.
Eu tava em um dilema.
Eu vou dizer
ou vou esconder?
Meus irmãos...
Ninguém esconde nada de mãe.
Tá na Bíblia isso.
Vanderson, Capítulo 3, Versículo 4.
Não escondei-vo-lhes
nada-lhes
de mãe.
Você pode fazer uma tatuagem
na rodela do cu,
o cara abaixa para pegar um chinelo,
"Menino, o que é isso aí?"
Ela tem um olho bom.
Pra merda, ela é boa.
Coisa boa ela não vê.
Bota ela pra ler, ela fica assim.
"Eu estou tonta".
Eu disse, eu vou fazer essa merda
e ela vai descobrir.
Vai brigar comigo.
É bandido, malandro,
descomungado, drogado,
Guns N'Roses, não sei o quê.
Eu disse, não, não vou fazer isso.
Só que eu morava a 800 km
da minha mãe.
Eu moro em Teresina, e ela
em Bom Jesus. Aí eu tive uma ideia.
Eu vou ligar pra minha mãe.
Antes de fazer a tatuagem.
Dizendo que eu já fiz
a tatuagem.
Para ver o que ela vai dizer.
Se ela brigar muito, eu não faço.
Se ela brigar só um pouquinho,
eu faço.
Porque brigar, ela ia.
Eu sabia.
Aí eu liguei e falei, "Mãe!"
"O que você quer?"
"Não é dinheiro, não."
"Pois fala."
"Eu fiz uma tatuagem."
"Mãe?"
Deu um minuto, e nada.
Dois minutos, nada.
Três, nada.
E eu preocupado,
coração, assim...
Eu suando,
quatro minutos sem falar nada.
Cinco minutos sem falar nada.
Cinco minutos sem falar nada!
De Tim pra Claro a ligação.
Pra você ter noção da minha agonia.
Eu não tava preocupado com ela,
mas com os bônus que estavam acabando.
E eu disse, "Mamãe!"
E aí ela falou, "Meu Deus!"
"O que foi, mãe?" "Meu filho tá nas
drogas." "Não é, mãe.
Mãe, tô de brinks."
"Você fez uma tatuagem
e botou brinco?"
"Não, mãe." Minha mãe é louca.
Minha mãe assiste TV em pé.
Não tem umas mães que fazem assim...
Cinco sofás sem ninguém.
Você pede para ela sentar,
ela zanga. Falta te bater.
Aí sai, deixa a TV ligada,
aí eu vou desligar.
Eu desligo, parece que joguei
uma pedra na cabeça dela.
Eu desligo e ela fala,
"Quem desligou?"
"Fui eu, ninguém estava assistindo,
eu desliguei." "Eu estou escutando!"
Do outro lado da casa.
Tiraram a audição da minha avó
e do meu avô e botaram nela.
Ela pode estar no Japão.
eu derrubo o controle no chão,
a voz vem do Japão.
"Quebra!"
Do nada.
"Você não sabe quanto custa?
"Não sei.
Vem junto com a TV."
Como é que eu vou saber?
Louca.
Você só pode levar em casa
os amigos que sua mãe conhece.
Geralmente ela conhece três.
O cara tem cinco mil amigos,
mas ela só conhece três.
Geralmente você não é nem amigo
dessas pessoas que ela conhece.
Ela sabe o nome, conhece o pai, a mãe,
sabe onde mora, fora esses três...
qualquer um que você leve na sua casa,
ela recebe com uma desconfiança...
Tão grande...
"Mãe, esse é meu amigo Barack Obama."
"Tudo bom, Obama?"
"Pronto."
"De brinco, né, Obama?"
"Eu não digo é nada."
Ela olha pro seu amigo por 15 segundos
e ela faz essa vergonha aqui...
"Filho, vem cá."
O pobrezinho não senta,
não pede água. Não fala.
"Quem é esse menino?"
"É um amigo meu."
"Engraçado que eu não conheço
esse menino.
Eu tenho pra mim que ele
é envolvido com drogas."
Eu tenho pra mim.
O que merda é "eu tenho pra mim?"
Se você tem, já é seu.
São duas coisas que mãe fala
que nunca entendi.
Uma é "eu tenho pra mim",
E a outra é quando
ela vai me contar
sobre um sonho que ela teve,
e ela diz que, "Alguém disse..."
Ela diz, "Whindersson, eu sonhei...
e diz que eu tava
com uma faca."
Eu digo, "Quem disse?"
"Diz que eu cheguei no carro, e..."
"Quem disse?
Tem um narrador no seu sonho?"
Disse... É louca!
Elas são doidas. Tem uma frase
que não sai da boca da sua mãe.
"Esses meninos um dia
vão me enlouquecer."
Não vamos, não.
Sabe o que enlouquece?
Ela, sozinha.
Mãe enlouquece sozinha.
Ela não precisa de filho
para enlouquecer.
Vou dar um breve exemplo.
Você tá almoçando,
normal, todo mundo almoça.
Meio-dia, uma hora...
Enquanto você está comendo,
ela está lavando louça,
e enquanto ela lava a louça,
ela conversa com outra mãe,
dentro da cabeça dela.
e começa a enlouquecer sozinha,
oide prestar atenção.
O cara tá comendo,
e ela tá lavando a louça, assim...
"Tem quem lava...
E olha onde ele tá? Comendo.
Só presta pra comer!
Quando eu acabar de lavar,
ele vem com o prato
e coloca aqui,
pra jumenta lavar.
Ai, ai...
Você acha que sou sua empregada.
Vocês vão dar valor
quando eu morrer.
Não satisfeita com as coisas
que ela fala sozinha,
ela fica com raiva do que ela pensou.
Ela vai tirar satisfação com você.
E você não tá sabendo
de nada do que ela pensou.
E ela ainda briga por uma coisa
que não tem nada a ver.
"Ei, tu!
Eu não vou comprar mais nada."
E sai, vai embora.
"Chega uma visita não tem mais nada.
Já comeram tudo.
Eu não tenho filho.
Eu tenho cachorros."
Isso dói, cara.
Dói porque é verdade.
Se deixar,
a gente come até as cadeiras.
A criança tem um mal.
A criança, ela nasce com um mal
chamado "Saber que tem."
Quando eu era menino,
com oito anos,
não conseguia dormir, pensando
no leite ninho que
tinha em cima do armário.
Não conseguia.
Virava pra um lado. Leite ninho,
leite ninho, leite ninho...
Eu queria dormir,
mas também queria pregar
1kg de leite ninho no céu da boca
e passar a noite toda
tirando com a unha.
Às vezes eu esquecia,
eu limpava o ouvido,
e eu botava na boca,
e vinha aquele gosto...
de dipirona.
Coisa ruim é
o gosto de orelha. Ave Maria!
A criança gosta, enquanto não acabar,
ela não aquieta.
Enquanto não acabar.
Um dia mamãe chegou em casa.
Chegou com um refrigerante.
Eu não olhei nem para ela.
Para mim era só um refrigerante
flutuando dentro de casa.
Eu fui acompanhando
o refrigerante.
Criança vê comida,
já começa a se coçar.
Ela botou o refrigerante
em cima da mesa.
Eu fiz a pergunta fatal
de toda criança.
"Mãe, a senhora vai
abrir agora, não vai?"
"Não!"
"Mãe, me dá um pouquinho?"
A criança, quando não consegue
o que ela queria,
ela fala bem devagarinho,
para ver se a mãe dá.
Ela olha para a mãe
e fala assim...
"Só um pouquinho..."
"Não!"
"Você é ruim..."
Aí começa a dar opções.
"Na xícara." "Não!"
"Na tampa." "Não!"
"Na minha mão." "Não!"
Não deu.
Mas eu não desisti, não.
Porque a criança quando vai a fundo e
não consegue, joga indireta.
Mamãe sentou lá fora e eu fiquei
ao lado dela assim...
"Que calor doido!
Acho que estou com sede.
Só que não é de água.
Meu short é preto.
Igual à cor do negócio
que eu vi ali.
No congelador.
Estou com vontade de tomar
uma coisinha com gás."
"O botijão está debaixo da pia,
pode pegar."
Não dava.
Mas também, quando ela me dava,
eu devolvia do mesmo jeitinho.
Ruim.
Mamãe me dava o refrigerante
eu ia tomar lá na porta de casa.
Fazer inveja ao meninos da rua.
Os meninos brincando,
e eu assim...
"O que é isso?"
"É Coca-Cola."
Menino é bicho ruim.
Criança é bicho ruim.
Já viu uma criança
quando ganha 25 centavos?
O que ela faz?
Ela compra alguma coisa? Não.
Guarda? Não guarda.
Passa o dia todo
com o dinheiro na mão,
mostrando a cada ser humano
que passa.
Ela canta. "Tu nem tem.
Meu pai quem me deu.
Que eu peguei no bolso de pai."
Faz mágica.
Você pode estar atrasado
pra pegar um voo pro Japão.
Uma oportunidade de emprego,
mas ela consegue te parar.
Para mostrar uma grande mágica
que ela sabe fazer.
Você passa correndo...
"Ei, tio."
O cara para, ela faz isso...
Perde o dinheiro.
De tão ruim que ela é.
Só existe uma pessoa
pior do que essa criança.
A mãe dessa criança.
Porque ela aprendeu com alguém.
Tem alguma mãe por aqui?
Aqui tem mãe?
Qual é o seu nome?
Etilândia?
Fala sério, deixa de brincadeira.
Etilândia.
Vamos para a Disney? Não.
Vamos para a Eti.
Hoje estou sem orçamento.
Vou ficar aqui pela Bahia mesmo
com Etilândia.
Tudo bom, Etilândia?
Etilândia, né?
Etilândia, coisa boa.
Etilândia.
Nome de velho, Etilândia.
Quando você pergunta,
"Qual o nome da sua avó?"
você nunca ouve, "Kathleen".
Etilândia, Raimunda, Peda,
nomes assim. Rosemeire.
Etilândia, só existe
dois tipos de mãe Terra.
Dois. A mãe do rico,
e a mãe do pobre.
A diferença entre as duas?
O modo de criar a criança.
O que a mãe do rico faz
quando o filho começa a correr?
Ela chama outra pessoa pra pegar o
menino porque não quer que ele caia.
"Não, Jarrod. Vem Jarrod, por favor."
Não pode, né?
Pelo amor de Deus, não pode.
O que a mãe do pobre faz
quando o filho começa a correr?
Ela chama outra pessoa
para ver o filho cair.
O menino começa a correr...
"Cláudia, vem cá!
Vem cá. Fica aqui.
Olha onde o capeta está."
A outra fala, "Vai buscar o menino!"
"Presta atenção, besta.
Vai perder?"
Na hora que o menino cai...
"Eu não falei?
Esse menino é o diabo, Cláudia!"
Ela deixa ele cair.
O tratamento é diferente.
O menino do rico, quando cai...
A mãe já vai correndo.
"Meu Deus, Jarrod.
Onde estão os bons modos?'
Macacos me morda, Jarrod."
É uma coisa tão linda.
Parece de filme.
O menino do pobre, quando ele cai,
é um quilômetro
que ela vem xingando.
O menino cai,
pode reparar, ela vem assim.
"Você é uma desgraça.
Tu já caiu, Vanderson?
Mas minha nossa!"
O choro das crianças é diferente.
O menino do rico, quando ele bate a
a cabeça no chão, e ele chora,
é lindo.
Parece que ele tá
no The Voice Brasil.
O menino do rico cai...
Não dá vontade de gravar um MP3
e mandar pro Spotify?
É lindo, é gostoso.
O menino do pobre, bate a cabeça e
ninguém sabe se é uma criança chorando
ou o SAMU chegando.
Do jeito que ele cai...
Os carros vão abrindo
um pro lado, outro pro outro.
Não dá.
E tem mais...
E choro de pobre é tudo igual.
Chora uma criança,
saem 15 mães das casas.
"É o meu?"
"Não é o meu, não.
O meu tem catarro.
Deixa no chão. Não é meu.
Pega, Etilândia, seu menino!"
EU sei não, Etilândia.
Uma coisa interessante
do menino do rico, que eu gosto.
São dois pontos bons.
Quer dizer, um bom, e um ruim.
O que foi?
Já sabe as piadas?
Está rindo antes de eu contar?
Uma coisa que eu não gosto
no menino do rico é que...
Eu quando eu era criança
eu não tinha muita condição.
Quando eu vejo um menino
negando comida, fico com ódio.
A gente quer dar um danone,
e o menino "Não quero."
Então dá para mim.
Sai. Eu como até o plástico.
Às vezes...
Uma coisa que eu gosto do menino
do rico é que eles são diretos.
Quando ele cai, ele chora.
Ele cai...
E a mãe vem pegar
pra cuidar do menino.
O menino do rico é direto, ele cai e
chora para avisar. O do pobre, não.
O pobre quando ele cai, parece
que fica sem entender o que aconteceu.
"Estava em pé nesse instante,
já viu isso?"
Ele tem um delay.
"Ei, tu nem me pega!"
Aí ele dá um sorriso, e ninguém sabe
se está sorrindo ou chorando.
"Foi por causa da pedra.
Eu não vou mais brincar.
Não é porque eu caí,
eu estou cansado!"
Aí é que ele chora.
Não leva um tempo?
Leva um tempo pra ele entender
o que aconteceu.
Eita, Vanderson...
Que vontade de cagar, Etilândia.
Quando mamãe sai pra trabalhar,
na casa do pobre,
quando a mãe sai pra trabalhar,
cada filho tem uma função.
É uma missão que a mãe
dá para cada um.
Essa tarefa é desempenhada
pela idade.
Quanto mais velho ele for, o grau de
responsabilidade da tarefa é maior.
"Você vai lavar,
você vai enxugar, você vai guardar."
É tipo uma empresa que a mãe monta.
Ela saiu com a casa suja.
Quando ela volta, está limpa.
Mas existe a tarefa
mais importante de todas,
que é chamada: encher as garrafas
de água da geladeira.
Só ficava para mim essa desgraça.
Eu tenho raiva disso
porque essa tarefa é fácil.
Então a gente não dá atenção,
não é como o cara que varre a casa.
O cara que varre a casa
sabe que a casa tem um tamanho.
Então tem um tempo
pra ele começar e terminar.
O cara que enche as garrafas, não.
Ele fica ali, sem fazer nada,
enquanto os outros estão varrendo,
fazendo as coisas.
"Whindersson, vai encher as garrafas."
"Vai varrer teu chão."
E mamãe me avisava. A gente briga
que a mãe bate, faz isso...
Mas antes, ela avisa
umas cinco vezes.
E ela não avisava igual
a mulher de filme, não.
"Olha, meu filho, encha essas garrafas
para que tenhamos água potável.
Vai, Jarrod."
Não.
Mamãe olhava para mim e falava.
"Whinderson,
quantas garrafas tem ali?
Quatro garrafas, não, é?
Ah, Whindersson.
Não me faça quebrar teu pescoço
quando eu chegar em casa.
Eu estou saindo para trabalhar agora.
Eu não vou te falar mais nada."
Ela saí, e já me dava
aquele gelo tão grande
que eu ia fazer logo.
Mas quando meus amigos vinham
que minha mãe saía para trabalhar,
ele já iam me chamar,
porque eles tinham medo dela.
Minha mãe era daquela que furava
as bolas que caíam em casa.
Eu tenho tanto amigo
que deseja a morte da mamãe,
você não tem noção.
E eles tinham medo da minha mãe,
então quando ela saía,
todo mundo ia pro meu portão.
E aí eu fui encher as garrafas,
mamãe saiu e eles...
Quando eu abri,
parecia a visão do inferno.
Que meninos feios!
Para a feiura,
ali não tinha preguiça, não!
Eram os piores espermatozoides
da minha cidade.
Ave Maria!
Era só coisa feia,
o nome deles já era feio.
Olha os apelidos: Catraca,
Placenta, Vanderson, só nome feio.
Eu não sei, juro que não sei,
como eu lidava com aqueles meninos,
todos tortos.
Braço de um,
perna do outro.
E todo grupo de amigos tem um líder.
Tem um líder.
E veio o líder falar comigo,
todo torto.
"E aí, otário.
Bora jogar?"
Eu disse, "Bora.
Jogar o quê?"
"Tu pedes."
Vocês já brincaram
de dubete?
Tem outros nomes, também.
Pau na lata,
taco, takibol, um monte de coisa.
Pra quem não conhece, eu vou explicar.
Duas latas de óleo,
do tempo da Etilândia.
Uma aqui, e outra aqui.
Na frente da lata... vai vendo.
Na frente da lata, tem um cara
com um bastão.
Uma ripa, que a gente achou,
quebrou em duas, deu uma pra cada.
Atrás da lata, um cara com uma bola,
para derrubar a lata do outro.
E quem tá com a ripa,
rebate.
E eu era o cara da bola.
Eu tinha uma mira...
Era impressionante.
Não errava uma.
Eu era o Neymar do bete.
Eu era a proparoxítona.
Eu era top.
Eu era daqueles
meninos boleiros,
igual os que descem do ônibus
com fone Beats, assim...
Eu chegava naquele naipe.
Só que eu cheguei
e tinha um menino diferente.
Loirinho, bonito, já não é amigo
meu, pensei.
Com os pezinhos rosa,
não é amigo meu mesmo.
Os pés dos meus amigos
eram cinza.
E não tinha Monange no mundo
que hidratasse aqueles pés.
Ave Maria!
Os meninos dos pés cinza,
o menino de sandália do Seninha.
Ele batia no chão,
piscava.
"Eita, Transformer!"
Tudo bem, achei bonito.
O cara veio assistir.
Só que ele pegou o taco.
Ele pegou o tal, e eu comecei
a me inchar. "Tá me desafiando?"
Quando ele pegou o taco
e me encarou...
eu enchi meu coração de rancor.
Eu vou mostrar pra esse mongoloide
como se joga.
Essa é a minha área.
Peguei a bola,
botei a força que eu tinha,
E joguei essa bola
mais ou menos 350 km Fahrenheit,
e eu disse, "Pega, galeguinho."
Meus amigos,
às vezes Deus deixa
a gente se achar o melhor.
Deus deixa a gente pensar
que a gente é o melhor.
Pra quando a gente chegar lá em cima,
mostrar que tem um galeguinho melhor.
Eu joguei essa bola numa habilidade,
com uma precisão,
numa potência...
Esse menino rebateu
com uma ignorância,
tão grande que a Terra
parece que ficou em câmera lenta.
Eu joguei a bola
e ele fez isso aqui.
Eu olhei pros meus amigos,
todos estavam assim...
Eu olhava para as folhas das árvores
e estavam caindo assim...
Tinha uma mulher de patinete na rua.
Quando ele rebateu...
O chinelo dela tinha um prego,
saía faísca,
parecia o "De Volta para o Futuro."
E os cabelos...
Cara, lindo!
E tudo em câmera lenta.
Tinha um velhinho passando na hora,
na velocidade dele mesmo, devagar.
E quando a bola passou,
eu disse, "Essa daí é minha."
E eu fui para pegar,
eu senti na ponta dos dedos.
Só que ela foi sumindo...
Sumindo, sumindo...
quando ela sumiu,
eu olhei para a esquina,
mamãe estava voltando para casa.
Eu falei: "As garrafas!"
Olhei para trás, cadê os meninos?
Cadê as latas? Cadê as ripas?
Eu tirei meu chinelo pra brincar,
cadê meu chinelo?
Etilândia, eu tava sozinho.
Abandonado, sem amigos.
Não tinha enchido uma garrafa...
e com dez anos de idade,
foi a primeira vez
que eu conversei com Jesus.
Eu te juro, eu olhei
para cima e disse, "Jesus,
Jesus?
Tá ligado que teu pai
é meu pai, né?
Me ajuda aí, cara!"
Etilândia, na hora!
Na hora, eu olhei pro lado
minha mãe parou a moto,
e começou a conversar
com a amiga dela. "Obrigado, Jesus!
Jesus, tu é Jesus mesmo, né?"
Bem aventuradas as crianças.
Mil garrafas cairão à tua esquerda,
dez mil à tua direita."
Não vai acontecer nada.
Eu fui bem devagarinho.
Luz total aqui para mim, por favor.
Eu fui bem devagarinho,
pelas paredes, no passinho do Romano,
pra ela não me ver.
Aí eu passei por trás da moto,
quando eu passei por trás da
minha mãe, a amiga dela me viu.
"Tu fica na tua!"
Eu fiquei atrás da minha mãe...
"Eu sou perigoso!"
Abaixei no portão,
e elas conversando.
Abaixei no portão.
O portão não via um óleo
há uns 15 anos.
O nome da minha mãe
é Valdenisse.
Eu puxei um centímetro,
e quase grita o nome da minha mãe.
Eu puxei, e ele, "Valdenisse!"
Eu dei aquele tempo,
para disfarçar.
Deu 10 segundos,
eu senti uma mão no meu ombro.
Tomara que seja Jesus.
Não vou perder essa oportunidade,
vou olhar para Jesus, quando eu olhei,
as unhas pintadas,
Jesus não pinta a unha.
Olhei para cima,
era a minha mãe.
Bateu aquele gelo.
Eu levantei, tentei disfarçar.
Fui confiando.
Entrei bem devagar,
disfarçando.
Passei do portão
e fui fechando.
Quando estava selando o portão, ela
disse "Quando eu entrar, tu vai ver."
Etilândia, me deu um gelo.
Porque o ruim para a criança
não é apanhar.
O ruim é saber que ela vai apanhar
daqui a pouco.
Porque ela começa a pensar coisas.
Quem é tua filha, Etilândia?
Está aí do seu lado, né?
Já deu umas palmadas?
Normal ou de leve?
De leve, né?
Mamãe também me batia de leve.
Tirei raio-X um dia desses,
minha coluna é torta de leve.
Mas é só de leve,
coisa de um palmo e meio.
Às vezes é bom apanhar.
Não pra quem está batendo,
pra quem apanha.
Etilândia, a surra
é o pagamento de uma dívida.
Pagamento de uma dívida.
Um exemplo,
você deu umas palmadas na sua filha,
deu 30 segundos,
ela está brincando e sorrindo.
A surra é o pagamento de uma dívida.
Quando você quebra um prato,
você está devendo a sua mãe.
Quando você leva uma surra,
ela não lhe deve mais nada.
Por isso que ela brinca sorrindo.
Tem uma grande diferença
entre o choro antes
e depois de apanha.
O de antes de apanhar
é uma atuação que não tem
Tarcísio Meira no mundo...
Mamãe entrou em casa,
quando olhou pras garrafas...
Eu fiz...
"O que é isso?"
"Mãe, a senhora vai me bater?"
"Whindersson, vem cá."
"Não!"
Eu corri pro canto,
e a mãe quando chega no canto,
ela não bate no canto,
ela traz pro meio da sala.
Ela me puxando e eu, "Não!
Não!"
Ela parou e fez...
"Nem doeu!", e só saí.
Fui embora.
Só de boa, Etilândia.
Não doeu nada para mim.
Você já bateu em sílabas?
Já pegou pelo braço e disse,
"Vo-cê-vai-a-pren-der..."
Já?
Mamãe me batia tão forte em sílabas,
que eu chorava em sílabas.
"O que você tem?"
"Mãe-me-ba-teu."
O menino do pobre, quando termina de
chorar, parece que tá ligando a moto.
"Mãe-me-ba-teu..."
Se subir em cima dele,
vai até o Piauí a 120km/h.
A criança é bicho sem vergonha.
Eu era sem vergonha
e muito burro.
Eu dizia, "Ei, mãe!
Amanhã eu fui pra escola."
"Não é amanhã, é ontem."
"Não, ontem eu também vou."
Eu trocava. Burro!
Etilândia, um dia minha mãe
me pegou batendo punheta.
Não ri, foi paia.
Eu não tinha nada pra fazer.
Não tinha um entretenimento.
Um danone, um cream cracker...
Um vídeo game... não tinha nada.
Criança danada.
O menino é danado,
a menina, não.
A menina até os 13 anos,
ela descobre que um menino gosta dela,
e pega ódio. Nojo.
Raiva. Mas o menino com três,
vai mijar, já faz assim.
Ele sabe onde está a diversão.
Ele não é besta.
Ele mede com os amigos.
"A minha tem 5 cm."
"E a minha que tem 6!"
Só que a criança é diferente.
Ela é inocente, não é como o adulto.
O adulto é muito esperto.
Já viu um adulto
assistindo pornografia?
Ele assiste, mas sabe que alguém
pode chegar a qualquer momento.
Ele assiste,
fica assim...
Já viu uma criança
assistindo pornô? É assim...
Pega no courinho,
de vez em quando
vê se está temperado.
Sazon...
É bom.
Cheirinho de Sazon.
O pai quando pega o menino
no flagra, não dá nem fé.
Ele não presta atenção, não
vê que tem alguém atrás.
O pai é bom
porque o pai ajuda.
Ele já passou por isso, Etilândia.
Tá se acabando na punheta.
"Eu vou beber uma água."
Aí o menino espanta.
Muda o canal,
aumenta o volume.
A mãe, não. Parece que ela
vem com uma bomba de fumaça.
"Você está fazendo o quê?"
O menino espanta,
a rola entra, sai no cu.
Depois é obrigado
a mijar de cócoras.
"Não dá!"
É difícil.
Não é, Vanderson?
É difícil, cara.
Esse dia que minha mãe me pegou
foi estranho.
Eu já era esperto,
eu botava o dedo
no botão de mudar.
Não tinha nada para fazer.
Era meia noite,
papai e mamãe
tinham dormido.
Eu liguei a televisão.
Cine Privé.
Fiquei no ponto. Dedo no
botão de mudar.
Se fosse vesgo era melhor ainda.
Um olho na TV e outro na porta.
Nunca pegaram o Luan Santana.
E eu de boa aqui na minha,
só no courinho,
Sazon.
Acho que minha mãe brotou
da cerâmica.
Eu só ouvi a voz de mãe.
Quando pega menino no flagra, sabe?
Vem fininha e vai engrossando...
"O que é isso aí?"
Mudei o canal.
Botei na Igreja Universal.
"Você está fazendo o quê?"
"Assistindo o culto!"
"Assistindo o culto?"
"Não. Estou aprendendo libras."
Aquele menino do cantinho, sabe?
"Tá aprendendo o quê, vagabundo?
Vai pro quarto."
Fui pro meu quarto zangado.
Queria quebrar as coisas.
Mas não pode, senão apanha.
Cheguei no quarto...
"Esse quarto é meu. Meu!"
Peguei meu notebook. "Meu.
Minha mãe comprou, mas me deu.
É meu."
Peguei meu fone de ouvido,
botei no meu ouvido,
entrei no meu site,
www.xvideos.com.br.
Era quase meu.
Já tinha assistido tudo.
Sempre vejo filme pornô
de cara com a rola menor que a minha,
pra eu não ficar mal.
Aí eu botei, "Vanderson...
Vanderson com um anão."
Dei o play, mas não
vou assistir no volume 1. Botei no 50.
Na TV a gente abaixa com medo.
Mas aqui, estou de fone.
Não, vamos botar no 80.
Não, 90.
Aí fiquei olhando...
Por causa de 10.
100. Aumentei todinho.
E isso era de madrugada.
Não tinha ninguém acordado
na Terra.
Aquele silêncio.
Sabe aquele silêncio da madrugada
que você assusta
quando estala um osso seu?
O cara vai beber água,
faz...
Eu dei o play e começou...
Só no fone...
Só no fone.
Não tava incomodando ninguém.
De madrugada,
não tinha ninguém acordado, silêncio.
E no meu fone...
E o Vanderson no anãozinho.
Às vezes ele judiava,
fazia...
Eu fui me mexer na cama,
o notebook foi pra um lado,
o fono pro outro.
Ecoou na cidade inteira.
Tava tipo assim...
"Oh, yes! No!
No! No!"
Meu irmão!
Vocês não estão entendendo.
É sério.
Eu fechei o notebook tão rápido
que ele era Windows XP,
virou Windows 8.
E ele continuou,
tem uns que fecha e ele não desliga.
"Que merda. Mamãe vai vir."
Mamãe acorda
com qualquer coisa.
"Mamãe vai vir.
Mamãe vai vir.
Vou fingir que estou dormindo.
Vou fingir que tô dormindo
faz horas."
Deu uns 15 segundos, a porta abriu...
E eu só assim...
Mamãe disse,
"Whinds?"
Eu dei aquela mastigada
pra enganar.
Aí ela gritou, "Whinds!"
Eu fingi aquela depressão,
quando a gente acorda.
"Whinds, tu escutou um barulho?"
Aí eu me superei.
Eu juro, eu olhei pra ela
e fiz assim...
"Que barulho?
A senhora está ficando doida,
vai dormir."
E ela foi.
É muito fácil
enganar a minha mãe.
Tudo para ela é alma.
Sério. Tudo para ela é alma.
Tudo pra mamãe é alma.
"Você foi na cozinha ontem?"
"Fui."
"Pensei que era uma alma.
Ouvi um barulho na pia."
"A alma vai vir lá do céu
pra lavar louça?
Você é louca!"
Eu era danado
quando eu era criança.
Muito danado.
Eu corria. Criança adora correr.
Elas fazem amizade correndo.
Em 30 segundos ela roda a concha
acústica e volta com 98 amigos.
Sem saber nem o nome.
Pode prestar a atenção.
Não sei como é.
Passa um,
e ela vai...
Chega para mãe...
"Olha o amigo que eu fiz,
faz tempo."
"Qual o nome dele?"
"Qual o seu nome?"
Aí conhece o menino.
Mas existe um fenômeno
muito grande chamado "faltou perna".
Às vezes o menino corre...
Ele corre demais e
o peito passa da perna.
E você corre com as pernas
tentando acompanhar o peito.
Às vezes você não tá de boa,
e passa um menino assim...
E você não consegue pará-lo.
Você só consegue olhar
e calcular onde ele vai cair.
Eu dei uma corrida dessa
porque eu estudava de manhã.
E minha aula acabava 11:40, e o Dragon
Ball acabava 12:00.
Nesses dia era Goku e Freeza.
Caralho, tenho que correr.
Eu corri
como se não houvesse amanhã.
Eu corri como um...
um turista lá no final do Pelourinho,
e o cara da fitinha tá lá em cima.
"Uma fita, uma fita!"
Eu corri mesmo. Voado.
Chegou na frente de casa,
faltou perna.
E a criança é foda, porque
volta da escola com a bolsa.
E a bolsa dá um solavanco.
O primeiro mortal
de uma criança é com a bolsa.
"Vou só amarrar meu cadarço."
Cai. É o primeiro
mortal de uma criança.
E eu vim...
E faltou as pernas,
e eu caí, na frente de casa.
Tanto lugar no mundo
pra eu cair,
e caí na frente de casa. mamãe vinha.
Pensei, "Vai me ajudar."
Aonde?
Eu levantando, tirando barro,
e mamãe vindo.
Quando ela chegou,
parou na porta.
São três coisas que tenho
medo que mamãe fale.
"Quando chegar em casa
a gente se acerta."
Principalmente quando ela pega pelo
braço e fala sem mexer os lábios.
Às vezes o cara está correndo
num aniversário,
correndo de boa.
Bate, derruba os refrigerantes.
A gente fica olhando aquele
bolo bonito.
Aí canta parabéns,
eles escondem o bolo,
e vem com uma vasilha
cheia de bolo no papel alumínio.
É ruim,
fica com raiva e joga no chão.
Mamãe me puxou pelo braço,
"Quando chegar em casa,
a gente se acerta."
Ela olhou pra uma amiga
e disse assim, "Oi!"
Saiu puxando,
ali acabou minha vida.
A segunda coisa,
"Quando seu pai chegar,
você vai ver."
Dava um minuto,
eu ligava pro papai.
"Pai?
O senhor está onde?
O senhor vem que horas?
Mamãe já falou com o senhor?
Não é nada, não.
Quando ela ligar, não atende.
Tá bom. Pai,
te amo."
Pra se livrar do abismo.
A terceira coisa que tinha mais medo,
não é uma frase, só uma palavra.
É quando ela para na porta
aponta pra dentro e faz, "Passa!"
"Mamãe vai me bater."
Minha mãe era tão cínica,
com um cinto na mão,
ela falava,
"Não vou não, besta. Passa!"
E eu dizia, "Solta o cinto!"
"Passa."
Eu não confiava, não.
Eu batizei minha mãe
de Yu-Gi-Oh.
Quando ela perdia o cinto,
já tinha colocado o chinelo
em modo de defesa virado para baixo.
Com mamãe, não dá, não.
Mandava passar, eu ia fazer o quê?
Eu morava ali.
Eu tomava distância,
porque não sou besta.
E eu corria, tinha o replay.
Agora, pela primeira vez
em Salvador,
em slow motion.
É a mesma cena,
só que agora
em super câmera lenta.
Todos os detalhes que não
puderam ver a olho nu.
eu olhava para a minha mãe.
Chegava dentro de casa,
eu comemorava.
Lá dentro, estava meu pai,
"Olha para trás!"
Quando olhei,
olha o cinto...
Não dava, não.
E mamãe
era igual ao Megazord.
O Megazord não dava um golpe
e ainda fazia uma pose?
Mamãe era igual.
Às vezes ela deixava eu passar,
ela fazia assim, "Meu Deus..."
Explodia.
Era lindo.
Mamãe.
Mamãe era demais.
Esse aqui, ou bateu muito
ou apanhou muito.
Tem que ser assim, mesmo.
Eu paguei, e vou rir até morrer.
Tem gente que é assim.
Dá 70 conto...
"Cadeira!"
"Cadeira..."
Ria, minha filha. Ria!
Coisa boa é sorrir.
Quando pequeno,
eu tinha raiva de inglês.
Eu pensava que as pessoas
estavam me xingando.
Eu achava que estavam me xingando.
"How are you?"
"How are you é tua mãe,
aquela vagabunda."
Eu tinha raiva.
Ninguém sabe cantar em inglês.
Diz que sabe, mas não sabe.
Quem nunca fez assim?
Não é? É o inglês mais lindo
do mundo.
É muito bom
cantar desse jeito.
Todo mundo sabe o refrão.
O "no" a gente sabe!
Agora o...
Esse a gente não sabe.
Muito obrigado, Salvador!
Até a próxima!
Que Deus abençoe vocês!
E leve vocês em paz
pras suas casas. Tamo junto, Salvador!
Vamos fazer aquela foto
bem bonita pra eu postar?
Quando eu disser um, dois, três, já!
Todo mundo levanta a mão.
"Ae, filha da puta!"
Galera de Salvador!
Um, dois, três e já!
Valeu, Salvador!
Tamo junto!
Que Deus abençoe vocês!
Foi foda!
Valeu, Salvador!
Tamo junto!